So my work is about
what you smell when
you walk into this rain forest.
And that smell is
plant volatiles.
In this rain forest
that's under glass,
the volatiles are
trapped by the glass,
and they're not destroyed by UV.
So they can accumulate
such large amounts,
they can burn your nose in here.
I'm studying, particularly,
the volatiles that help plant
leaves to deal with stress,
like from high temperatures
and drought.
These volatiles help plants
to deal with climatic change.
But they also, in turn, feed
back to affect the climate.
And they're stored as oil.
But once you break them free,
then just like a perfume
that you would
spray on yourself,
that oil gradually is released
into the air, becoming a gas.
We used to go on
vacations to Costa Rica
whenever we could on Christmas
break when I was a kid.
So I became fascinated with
tropical forests there.
So once I decided to
get into sciences,
then I set my track to get
back to the tropical forest,
kept working there, learned how
to identify plants, came here,
and I've just kept
doing it since.
Here, I can plug into AC power
while I'm working on the leaves
right out inside the
forest, which is amazing.
I know that it's
not going to rain,
because the people
at the energy center
didn't hit the
button to say rain.
If I want to see how
plants respond to drought,
we just turn off the
rain for a while.
You have
three-dimensional access
to any point inside the biome.
Salad tongs for timing.
You can climb up
the space frame.
And you can drop
ropes to anywhere.
And then you can repel
down to that point.
You can haul instruments
up to yourself.
That is still difficult,
hard, hot, grueling work.
But it's easier than climbing
trees, which I've also
done in the real world.
And yeah, that's much
harder, and more dangerous.